foreign
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS of
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsey show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships I am Ramsay
personality Rachel Cruz hosting today
with Bella rims personality and
best-selling author Christina Ellis and
we are taking your calls about anything
again life money relationships career
and it's a free call anywhere in the
country at triple eight eight two five
five two two five so give us a call and
we can help help you out where you need
it so first up we have Brad and
Rochester
hey Brad welcome to the show
Hi how are you guys we're doing well how
can we help
I have a question about uh we're trying
to pay off our mortgage early
um and how aggressive I should do that
but my main thing I'm concerned with I
mean we have a fully funded emergency
fund and no debt besides the house and
I would like to well we're saving 17 and
a half percent into our uh our
401ks combined okay and should I reduce
that to 15 I have 207 000 to pay off on
the mortgage yet two hundred and seven
thousand okay uh yes I mean for sure I
would lower that to that 15 because
you'll take that extra that extra cash
and yeah throw it at the mortgage to pay
it off to pay it off early how how much
money do you guys make a year
we may combine 260 000. oh good job
that's awesome what a great goal how
what's your time projection for when
you're going to have this paid off well
including some stocks that I have from
my company
um half of them will invest uh in July
so I want to sell those and then two and
a half years after that I saw those two
we think we can do it in two and a half
to three years
um without reducing our 401K down to 15
the reason I'm concerned with reducing
is I'm 51 and she's 50.
um so I want to put as much as I can
into yeah 1K for sure how much how much
do you guys have it in it now
combined about 900 000. oh yeah you're
doing great Brad no I mean I think
you're fine I think I mean I if I were
you I'd still go down to that 15 again
any extra money that you have throw it
at the principal of the house and as
soon as you have that paid off then yeah
you guys are right into baby step seven
which means you guys can go back up and
invest that 17 even more 18 19 of your
income if you wanted to uh but just
being able to to nothing it's not going
to make that big of a difference
honestly in just those two years of
lowering it two and a half percent I
understand what you're saying and I get
the
um yeah the intensity of like oh man we
can keep throwing this because you have
a plan of other ways that you're going
to be selling off that stock and paying
off the house but uh I would go ahead
and just lower it and and start knocking
off knocking the house down yeah
knocking out sound don't knock your
house down but knocking down the
mortgage yeah don't do that but the snow
we're having this week probably wouldn't
do that yeah I saw Minnesota I was like
yeah
um yeah and I think especially too with
like such a solid income y'all are
investing so well and we're not talking
about the difference between you know
five to ten years of paying off your
house early this is just going to be a
small change so I think it's going to
feel good emotionally to have both
things solid that's right so great
thanks Brad thanks for the call up next
we have Rob and Los Angeles hey Rob
welcome to the show
hello so I
I wanted to pay off all my debt
um about eight months ago so I had a
couple side houses going on and actually
made quite a lot of money in the side
hustles and now on face I just did my
taxes and I did them I started doing
them myself and I
deal enough it calculated out to about
that I owe thirteen thousand dollars
that I just didn't plan for
um and now I feel like I just kind of
screwed myself up even more
um trying to get out of debt so tell us
more about your situation so you said
you kind of started these side hustles
trying to get out of debt how much debt
do you have
well now I don't have any besides the
mortgage I mean my wife and I would paid
off everything and good got rid of the
car and were the side hustles like 1099s
what were the side hustles you were
doing
it was mainly
um like project management based stuff
but I just did it myself just just
self-employed stuff yeah so yeah and it
ended up being you know sixty thousand
dollars that I made on the side hustle
yeah that's great just some project
management stuff which I mean it was but
I didn't plan for for any of enough for
taxes I should say so with the money
that you made was that just all going
towards debt do you still have any of
that saved up or what's going to happen
with that money we have yeah we have a
okay emergency fund
um and I guess I mean I guess the the
answer is that I would use that but it
just feels like I'm taking a step
backwards again then
well what how much do you have in your
emergency fund
um there's about 20 000.
okay just just over it yeah
so you have no no more debt twenty
thousand dollars in an emergency fund
and you owe thirteen thousand dollars in
taxes
okay so so mathematically rob you pay
yeah you you have the money you pay for
it emotionally is where you're
struggling because you're thinking oh my
gosh and I hate to say it California New
York have some of the highest taxes in
the country so you probably do have a
huge tax bill and again it's yeah you
forgot about it you didn't calculate it
correctly and it is what it is but and
you have to pay the taxes you have to
pay taxes and so I know it sucks to feel
like oh my gosh we paid off all of our
debt we have a great emergency fund but
yo taxes Rob I mean like you know
there's really no way around it so it
really is just you swallowing the
emotion of the eye roll of oh my God
this is so annoying and you pay it and
you keep moving forward but you have the
money I mean you're you're in a great
spot I would I would tell you no
different right you you have the ability
to pay for it and you need to pay for it
if not I was going to say that's going
to be your next goal I thought you were
going to say you had nothing in savings
you know a thousand dollars and that's
it and then you're gonna have a journey
of side hustles again in order to pay
the taxes on it but now uh it's a it's a
great end of the story so what's making
and you struggle is it just the emotion
of it that just sucks and you're just
calling us to be like what it's just
terrible we're all going to just sit
here and talk about how terrible taxes
are
you I just feel I mean somewhat like
it's been the whole process of just kind
of feeling like a little bit of a
failure where I got myself into that
position to begin with
um and
and just and then and then not planning
it out properly and and you just you
just feel like why did I even no I mean
I kind of might feel like why did I even
bother like where everything was okay
before like I didn't want to be in debt
but it didn't hit me hard like this and
I guess you know I understand I have the
money to pay it off but sure it's just
emotion emotionally is hard yeah and it
probably takes a hit to your pride of
like oh wow I didn't calculate it and
think about it and so but I would Rob
much whether be in your situation where
you are than have no savings and a lot
of debt and so you did the right thing
hear us say that we talk about making
extra income living like no one else
sacrificing your lifestyle doing all of
this to get out of debt and you did that
Far and Beyond and exceeded uh an
incredible goal by doing that yeah but
then you got to be a grown-up we all get
we all we all gotta pay taxes and so
that's just kind of part of the gig so
no you didn't do the wrong thing I get
it's probably a hit to your pride that
oh wow I didn't think through this all
the way to the end that's okay Rob you
got the money pay for it yeah you're
debt free and thanks for this call
because for all of you out there who are
doing side hustles for the first time
this is an important note you need to
set aside money for taxes that just has
to happen that's right this is the
Ramsey Show
[Music]
we've been doing business at Ramsey for
more than 30 years by now we're a
well-oiled machine but it wasn't always
that way yes we've always had a vision
always had determination and a drive to
help people but what we didn't have was
one central place to access all our
numbers so that we could get further
ahead or quickly see when we needed to
Pivot we were always jumping back and
forth between different systems and
spreadsheets so when netsuite by Oracle
helped us Wrangle our Revenue inventory
expenses and more into one place it was
a game changer and netsuite's number one
Cloud Financial system can help your
business gain the same visibility
because businesses thrive on timely data
and next week's real-time analytics can
help your business have immediate access
to your numbers daily so you always know
where you stand and you can move quickly
so go to netsuite.com Ramsey today a and
set up a free product tour that's
netsuite.com Ramsay
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsay show well the
Building Wealth live events are
happening and there's one in Austin
Texas tonight with Dave Ramsey Dr John
deloney Ken Coleman and Jade warshaw and
they are so excited to hang out with you
guys there in Austin we had one last
week that I was on with George camel and
Jade warshaw in Indianapolis and it was
absolutely incredible and you know as we
were talking as a team as we were
building out these events we were kind
of just tired of hearing the lie that
you just can't get ahead today it feels
like everything is Doom and Gloom
everything is against you and we just
have the opposite Approach at Ramsey we
really believe that you can step into
your financial situation change your
money habits and actually build wealth
so if you feel like though gosh you're
kind of confused because you're hearing
stuff on the news you're seeing stuff on
social media and you want to clear all
of that and truly learn how to build
wealth we want to help you we want to
walk beside you and help you build
wealth that will change your family tree
so the next events coming up will be
with Dave Ramsey George camel Christina
Ellis and myself and we are going to
Salt Lake City Utah April 24th my
birthday Eve oh the eve of my birthday
I'll be there Salt Lake celebrating with
you guys and then Dr John deloney King
Coleman Christina Ellis and Dave Ramsey
are heading to Anaheim California on May
2nd so again April 24th Salt Lake City
May 2nd Anaheim so make sure to get your
tickets every Building Wealth event that
we've had has sold out by the time the
event comes so make sure to get your
tickets today before they're gone at
ramseysolutions.com events
and we're gonna head to the phones again
and it is a free call anywhere in the
country at triple eight eight two five
five two two five so up next is Adam and
Lynchburg Virginia hey Adam welcome to
the show
hey thanks for having me on absolutely
how can we help
hey so um I am 16 years old and I'm
about to start a new job with a local
house washing company here in uh our
town where I live and um it's a pretty
good hourly rate our hourly rate but
it's probably not gonna be a super
long-term thing probably a couple years
maximum I'm also uh considering college
for acting and Film Production but I'm
not really sure if I can afford it right
now I'm trying to look into hate grants
and stuff like that and uh I also you
know don't want to have to take out
loans or anything obviously so
um basically my question is should I
pursue college and kind of go long term
or Gore or a billboard immediately and
kind of try to get with this job now and
save up as much money as possible start
investing early Etc
I love the fact that you're 16 and
you're asking this question what grade
are you in
I'm graduating
oh at 16. that's awesome yeah did you
graduate early did you homeschool or how
did that happen
yeah I did homeschool uh I started
school a year earlier than a standard
and then uh I'm not exactly sure why but
for some reason I was able to skip a
message yeah no it's great good for you
okay smart guy yeah are you working
full-time right now
um I was working full-time but uh that
job was kind of put on pause for now and
I'm actually working at my local church
and I'm working there with another guy a
friend of mine and so I'm making a
couple hundred dollars every every other
week there but um if that's not anything
long term so so you want to go to
college right now just part-time okay
you want to go to college I haven't
right
yeah I um I haven't completely decided
honestly it's constantly had gone uh
back and forth about for a long time but
um I I've kind of considered like what I
want to do and I kind of always find
myself being drawn back to something
like acting or Film Production producing
directing Etc and so I know the probably
the first uh realistic step to that is
college so that was my uh thought
process there well if you want to go to
college you can go debt free
and I noticed I know it's intimidating
when you see the news and there's so
much about student loans and there's
such a myth right now that in order to
get a college degree you have to go into
debt and with our documentary borrowed
future with my message I am all about
teaching people how to go debt free now
you may have to have a creative strategy
you may need to go to Community College
first maybe go to a public school maybe
work like you're doing now but if you
want to go then we can figure out a
strategy
um it does sound like with what you want
to do you're interested in going to
school and also I love that you have
this work ethic already one of the
programs I'm super excited about that
kind of has been growing recently are
tuition assistance program so basically
you can have a full-time job with some
sort of company and while you're working
they're paying for your college
education so you can go debt free so
you're earning a paycheck like you're
doing now and getting to go to school
for free so I think with your work ethic
that sounds like that could be a good
fit for you how do you feel about that
that's definitely something I'd be
interested in looking into I don't
really know exactly where to start with
all that honestly but that does that
definitely sounds like something that
could work for me this is going to sound
like the most basic advice ever but
Google
Google is a great place to start for
that just literally look up tuition
assistance programs in your area type in
your city and look for tuition
assistance programs and you can find
incredible results it sounds almost too
easy it feels like there should be some
complicated you know search process but
just start looking online and figuring
it out now I'm going to offer you an
alternative Point of View kind of
channel the internal Ken Coleman you
know perspective where it's like if you
want to go into film and acting you
don't necessarily need to go to college
I mean we've talked to several we had
production people here at Ramsey who you
know do film they do camera production
and a lot of them learned their skills
from YouTube
well that and Adam have you been around
Austin our producers he's pointing at
himself right now uh Adam have you been
around that industry that you you've
been around it that you thought oh yeah
I had this experience here or there that
really made me interested or is it kind
of just this idea in your head out there
that you've seen it from a distance and
just think it's really intriguing and
interesting what where are you at in
that
yeah probably the latter I um I'm not
really close up with it I haven't seen a
lot of it firsthand per se yeah but so I
think my advice Adam and again it kind
of sounds wild because you're 16 right I
mean like you've just done all this life
so quickly with school and all that so
you're at a position that I would say if
you if there's any chance I'm trying to
think in Lynchburg if there is I'm not
sure but if there's anything around that
world
again even like a news station or
something great if you can go Shadow
anyone that's doing some type of you
know whether it's camera work or again
if there's Film Production uh local
community stuff like if there's anyone
or anything that you can go and just
Shadow I think that that's a great
option I think you know when when you're
16 17 18 19 20 21 that that like kind of
ladder High School into college it
always scares me a little bit Christina
where I'm like we make these 18 year
olds go and invest all of this money to
get a college degree in something that
they think they want to do and the
majority of people don't even use that
college degree for the job that they
have and so I'm like man when it comes
to real life experience that's going to
be one of the best teachers Adam to help
guide you because honestly things can
look glamorous from the outside and then
when you get into the nitty-gritty you
think oh gosh actually this is way more
miserable than I than I thought maybe
this isn't what I want to do you know
what I'm saying like if you could have
any level of real life experience
against shadowing someone or being on
set somewhere for a little bit I think
that's either going to draw you closer
to that passion and say wow this really
is
happening in my in my spirit of like
this is what I want to do this this is
the right direction or maybe like no
actually I want to go to code school and
be a computer programmer like I don't
know what it is so I would say you know
keep keep those options open and if
again if you can have any real life
experience I would recommend that and
like Christina said look for options
that you may not need a degree or if you
do I mean there is you know film and you
know acting degrees out there uh
depending on you know specifically what
um what line you're thinking of in that
career and look around and just you know
shop options apply for scholarships and
grants like Christina saying all these
other programs uh but yeah if you choose
the college route Adam uh definitely do
it debt free but I would say look into
that specifically as much as possible
and if you're open to moving I've heard
Disney has a great tuition assistance
program so you can potentially work
somewhere strategic where you're getting
those skills you're getting the
experience you're seeing it firsthand
and you're getting your education so I
mean look at creative options because
you really could do both yeah it's great
well Adam thanks so much for the call
again like Christina said always
impressive when we get young people that
call and they want to know how to start
this you know this journey of being wise
with their money so early which is
absolutely incredible so thanks again
Adam again it's a free call anywhere in
the country at triple eight eight two
five five two two five I'm Rachel Cruz
and this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
foreign
y'all there's a lot you can't control
when it comes to health care but there
is something you should check out that
can help Christian Healthcare Ministries
chm is not Insurance it is
budget-friendly biblically based Health
cost sharing that means a community of
members helping share the burden of each
other's health care costs they help
people just like you in all 50 states so
see if chm could be right for your
family learn more today at
chministries.org budget
[Music]
thank you
so one of the things when it comes to
money and spending money is impulse
buying is always the thing that oh
breaks the budget things come up in life
spur of the moment or maybe something
comes up you're like oh I just totally
forgot to plan that and didn't put it in
the budget but this impulse buying is
something that if you're not aware of it
can be an everyday habit really of just
spending on impulse so Christina you and
your family did a no spin challenge in
January and you guys not only saved a
lot of money but learned a lot it was a
it was a truly a challenge to do yeah
yeah it really kicked a lot of our bad
habits we realized in December that our
budget was kind of fluffy and we needed
to tighten back up we just got in a bad
habit of when we're rushing around and
doing things just grabbing Chick-fil-A
or you know just doing things in a hurry
so we went through January and we were
super disciplined and once the no spin
challenge was done it's like man this is
like easy now we're not spending as much
on groceries I don't feel tempted to go
out to eat but then last week I had this
week where I was just my schedule was
packed and I had things in the evenings
and I was kind kind of rushing around
doing things and I caught myself like
going back to Chick-fil-A each night and
just like quickly like grabbing little
purchases here and there and after about
like three days I was like what am I
doing I'm starting to go back to this I
gotta stop uh so yeah I really checked
myself and was like what what is this
and I realized that when I get in a
hurry I tend to impulse purchase when I
have a lot of things going on when I'm
just kind of you know like oh my gosh I
gotta go to this thing and I forgot to
bring food and all of that so I was
helping lead an FPU class last night at
church and we were having this
conversation and a lot of people were
like yes that's when I tend to eat out
when I've got something in the evening I
didn't plan for when I'm in a hurry so
it really made me think about it like
how can we kind of prevent that feeling
of I'm in a hurry I feel stressed and so
I just need to grab something quick and
and kind of you know impulse buy and I
was doing the math and it's crazy how
those purchases really do up so it's
easy to be like okay it's just five
extra dollars a day no big deal but at
five dollars a day that's one thousand
eight hundred and twenty five dollars a
year just five dollars a day just a
careless little five dollars is almost
two thousand bucks in a year and if it's
twenty seven dollars a day which is easy
to do with kids if you run through
Chick-fil-A and get everybody meals like
27 bucks easy that's ten thousand
dollars a year ten thousand dollars just
gone and so it's really important to get
a handle on this especially you know
with our family we're like we've got
some big money goals so we really want
to keep this tight so yeah every little
bit it does it it adds up and that's why
one thing I love that helps me with
impulse buying is the budget because I'm
like okay we can look ahead and we try
to do this again life happens so it's
not always perfect but we do as much
planning as possible if we get the
calendar out and we're like okay you
know these are gymnastics nights right
for the for the girls and we're gonna be
home at six they're gonna be starving so
it's either going to be crock pot or
something like something easier at
Chick-fil-A uh but let's play plan it
out and actually have a plan so it's not
this reaction but we're being proactive
with our spending because then it makes
it doable because you can say okay if
we're going to be eating out because you
plan ahead of time this much does that
match up with our money goals and if
it's like no we need some more money to
hit these money goals then you start
shrinking those categories yeah and make
you plan around it because uh oh yeah we
do that not to pick on Chick-fil-A
because we love Chick-fil-A I might get
the red status on the app now I thought
that the other day I was like oh my gosh
I spent a lot of money at Chick-fil-A
but it was 41 for five of us to eat oh
41. and that's that's three kids meals
and two adult you know meals and you're
just like okay 41 at the grocery store
goodbye four to five meals for us we
could do spaghetti one night you could
do Taco I mean I could literally go
through a meal plan and
and I'm like you know what but we
planned it right for my defense like I
was like we knew on that night we were
gonna go out so we had planned it but
when that happens over and over and over
and over and over and you don't plan
that's what you're saying is I'm like oh
my gosh it does it adds up but when you
budget and you plan then you can know
okay is this going to help my financial
goals is this going to set us way back
that we don't have the margin for that
and it really is your guide yes it's
like permission to spend right so a lot
of people avoid the budget because they
know that they're out of control and
they're like I don't want to feel
restricted I don't want to do the budget
but it's like you can actually carve out
that space so that you don't have to
feel guilty you can go to Chick-fil-A
and enjoy it now that being said like
even if it's in the budget that doesn't
mean you want to use your whole budget
in the first two weeks of them that's
right that's right be strategic and to
do that it's helpful to use cash so that
is a big thing for us especially since
no spend we have gone back to the
envelope system I know that's like OG
Ramsay
um
the pain of like handing over physical
cash like it's a thing it is a like
there are studies psychological studies
about how your brain treats that
differently whenever you just swipe a
debit card then it's like you don't feel
that attachment to your money going away
but it's like when you have to hand the
cash over and you don't get it back
you're like yeah oh and then also you
can just look in your envelope and go
okay I don't have yes I don't have
anything left I can't spend more money
it's like a natural because there is
there is zero emotion with a credit card
because it's not your money at all like
you have no attachment to this number
that you're spending out there there's
not there's no emotion attached to it uh
a debit card may be a little different
because you know okay that's coming out
of my checking account like that's my
money leaving but you're still not
physically feeling it like you do with
actual cash and so it's interesting
Christina I I've had two interviews this
week with just different sources and
they both asked uh okay Rachel well
places don't take cash so they only
accept credit cards what do I do and I'm
like yeah because we are running into
some places some establishments are not
accepting cash but it just so you all
know and again not to like shame anyone
if you don't know this but I was shocked
that I got this question twice a debit
card works
at any place they take a credit card
it's run by the same system now
sometimes you put in your PIN numbers
you know or you do you run it as a
credit and sign but anywhere that
accepts a credit card will accept a
debit card so I talked to people that
this week because they didn't know and I
was like oh wow it's such you know just
a second-hand knowledge you know it's
just in my head I just know that but to
say it out loud for all you everyone
listening cash is amazing like you're
saying because you're actually feeling
it leave but also your debit card is
another place that you can use and if
and if your budget's attached to your
bank account and you have every dollar
that transaction comes in and you're
dragging and dropping those transactions
so you know exactly what is in each
category yeah that's so good um like the
granny in me is not ready for the world
to go away
that's like a whole okay
let's not get Rachel started uh but uh
there was a there was a study that came
out this week someone saw me on Monday
at our staff meeting at the number one
thing that germs are exchanged with I
thought it was gonna be kids I was like
kids they carry the most germs out of
anyone it's dollar bills oh gosh it's
it's money and then doorknobs is number
two Rachel we're trying to tell people
to use cash
I know I just thought that was an
interesting fact so very very
interesting wash your hands after you
use it you know I don't know okay back
to impulse spending
I love that you mentioned planning in
advance because that's one thing like
sitting down on Sunday and like laying
out your whole week think through the
nights that you have soccer practice
think through the night that you have to
volunteer at church that you get to
volunteer at church you know think
through that thing so it's not a
surprise you're not like oh wait I only
have 20 minutes I didn't think about it
like you thought about that you had a
plan and then I feel like a good backup
plan is like just having lots of snacks
I feel like that's like every mom out
there knows that but even for adults
like I've started carrying like one of
those meal replacement protein bars in
my purse so that like do you have one of
those nights where I'm like I'm running
from work to another thing I don't have
to go well the only option is to grab
something to eat I can just have have it
right there that's two bucks versus ten
yes we were somewhere with the kids two
weeks ago and there was a vending
machine which again kind of going back
to the old school days I'm like oh my
gosh a vending machine yeah I never see
him anywhere yeah and my kids were like
we're starving we're stuck Iranian so
they they wanted and I looked and
there's like Pirates Booty you know it's
all the snacks that we have at home and
it was two dollars for the and I looked
at them I was like no no we are not
we're gonna go in the car because I have
a snack bag in the car that I'm like we
will eat snacks in the car no we're not
spending two but I'm like that would
have been six bucks back to your first
example in five dollars a day I'm like
that would have been money so snacks
snacks snacks and to get you to the next
place or to get you through the meal
until you can eat later you know at home
or whatever and the last thing is just
to keep your goals in mind y'all
whatever baby step you're on whatever
your goal is repeat that to yourself so
we're trying to pay off a house so every
time I see a purchase that's like
impulsive I'm like is this worth the
house is this worth a paid off house it
is not and then I have the strength to
wait so good Christina thanks for
walking us through that I think it's so
helpful to get tactical when it comes to
our money and our everyday spending this
is the Ramsay show
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I am
Rachel Cruz hosting today with Christina
Ellis and we are taking your calls on
your life and your money so up next we
have Jennifer in Cherry Hill New Jersey
hey Jennifer welcome to the show
hey Rachel hey Christina how are you
guys doing we're doing great how can we
help
so I'm following the baby steps and my
husband and I really are banging it out
um we've paid off over 47 000 uh in 15
months oh my goodness amazing
yeah I kind of like it really is a
Snowball Effect it just kind of builds
and you get really exciting you're like
I gotta get this out of here that's
awesome so the last thing on our plate
is my student loan debt which is
relatively low compared to other people
it's less than 13 000. okay I'm not
waiting on biting Biden or any of that
kind of stuff
my thing is so lately my family my
parents and my husband's dad they've
been getting older obviously but also
sicker so my dad was just diagnosed with
diabetes my mom seems to have a health
problem every other week but legitimate
um yeah and his dad is starting to
forget who he is
um who his son is
um so my question is I kind of want to
sell the home we're in right now and
move closer to them and
this is kind of like where I'm thinking
you know microwave versus
um
crock pot which I've heard several times
on the Ramsey Show
um but I don't know like I feel like I'm
doing it for the right reason which is
family not just because I don't I love
my home I do
um and we only paid 209 for and it's
worth like 350 now
um and now houses are crazy so I'm just
I really want to move closer to my
family yeah absolutely are you are both
sets of parents close together location
wise
uh they're both South so if we move in
that direction for sure where do they
live
so
um let's see Mantua and Blackwood but in
the same state
it is I'm sorry it is in the same city
it's about 45 minutes
okay 45 minutes from where you're at now
yeah it's not horrible I just feel like
if this was like 20 minutes or yeah no
absolutely so yeah Jennifer I mean what
I I would say yes I would I I would make
the move if that's what you guys are
wanting but I would I would make it a
lateral move uh and get this you know
have close to the same consistent
mortgage that you have now so your house
is worth 350 how much you guys owe on it
we owe 180
696. okay
very specific you're so great uh yeah so
I mean when we talk about
buying a home that you want to have a
good down payment that your payments no
more than 25 of your income uh so we
have a lot of that formula on
ramsaysolutions.com if you want to look
more into that but I would say just make
sure it's for me it would be more of a
lateral move again that it doesn't take
you deeper into debt
um or if anything you downsize and get a
little bit of a less of a mortgage I
think it's great and you want to be able
to
um foresee some um moving costs and the
expense that comes with that and so when
it comes to moving we this is one of
those
um situations that we talk about if
there's a big life situation coming up a
health situation or you're pregnant or
you're wanting to move that this would
be a time to pause the baby steps and
save up some cash for those moving
expenses and do that so yeah I mean if
that's what you guys choose to do I I
think that that's totally totally okay
um if you guys know the time frame of
when you can pay off this 13 000 and it
feels like gosh we could knock it out
because we are so aggressive right now
and paying this off and do that and then
move I mean it's it's either way but I
just know how important family is and
that you said your parents you know
they're getting older you don't have you
don't know how much time is left and
being able to help them and be available
to them I think is really key so again I
wouldn't put yourself deeper in a hole
of debt I would make it a lateral move
but if you guys want to move locations
um I mean I see it Christina like you
know you're moving for another job or
something you know what I mean like
people move all the time
um but I would just make sure that again
financially that you guys do it smart
and not overly emotional and go buy
something crazy that you can't afford
yeah Jennifer that's what my husband and
I were talking I'm sorry oh no go ahead
go ahead
um the only thing is and I hate to add
something to it is my husband has skin
cancer and he knows he's taking off in
June about six weeks and he it's SML
Lane he'll get disability but we know
disability doesn't like come in like
that so I was actually going to start
stockpiling for that yeah while we're
waiting for disability to come in we've
got all the bills get paid still we're
not stressing about that I didn't want
him to stress about he asked if it's
taken care of but he was free he was
afraid to take off some work yeah and
I'm like no you've got like this is your
health okay so Jennifer this that I'm
glad you told us that because that adds
to the equation of what's going on in
the situation so I would pause moving I
mean obviously taking off the six weeks
for for a procedure
um for the cancer which I'm so sorry
that's so scary
um I would I would get through that
first because you guys probably will
have to save well you need to to save
extra money to be able to keep your
budget where it is while he's out for
six weeks not at all we thanks to Randy
we live so below our means it's
ridiculous we can do it on free
paychecks oh good okay okay well
Jennifer when you're thinking about
moving what's kind of the timeline you
have for that
okay so if I was doing the crock pot
taking my time a year
okay a year
um but part of me is like we should try
to do it in the next six months but his
surgeries not even his surgeries he has
to put stuff on his skin which will
cause him to scale and he can't work at
that time
so he's got surgeries in March which is
fine there's quick surgeries but then
he's got that
procedure we'll call it well he'll be
out for six weeks and one thing to
factor in is moving is pretty stressful
like there is I think I saw a study
whenever we were moving last year I was
feeling so stressed and was like this
feels like so much and then I saw
something where it was like moving and
send the top five most stressful events
that people typically got probably
sickness as well Jennifer so you have a
lot of that going on right yeah so it's
just factoring in like packing up the
house and what that's going to take in
the midst of walking through the health
Journey that could be a lot and I
wouldn't want you to get so far into
packing and prepping to move
um that you you don't really realize the
weight of it until you're in the midst
of all of it at the same time not that
moving's not a good thing but just
making sure to really factor in what is
that going to feel like to pack up our
entire house what's it going to feel
like to list our house on the market
like what is all of that actually going
to feel like and how much time is it
going to take in the midst of walking
through your husband's journey in the
midst of still wanting to take time to
be with both sets of parents like there
there's just a lot of factors
to consider that are all going to take
time and the other thing I'm thinking
too is you know if you do end up taking
the bit slower route and moving in a
year you did say like you powered
through forty seven thousand dollars in
debt you feel so much momentum right now
how much you guys make a year Jennifer
sorry Christina uh 161 000. oh okay okay
so y'all could knock out this Step 13
quick right we could if I wasn't pausing
it because of his health at first like
that's the first priority not moving
okay so you've already paused it to be
able to say about for June is that
correct uh well we just paid off his
401k so we were paying that off and now
we're going to pause it so technically
as of like last week it's Paul's but you
said you're going to be able to get
through it comes in we'll go aside okay
but there you don't have to set a ton
aside right you said three paychecks
no yeah we don't have a set I was going
to set everything aside should I not do
that
no everything extra yes yeah but but
you're saying though you can have enough
saved up for those six weeks that he
will not be working you can do that in
three paychecks is that what I heard
I was saying that we can pair bills in
three paycheck oh okay okay okay I hear
you I hear you I'm sorry
um no it's okay because like so when I
say three paychecks I mean like we get
four I get two he gets two yes yes okay
throughout the month so you all have set
yourself up to be in a good position
where there's not really a wrong answer
like if you move you've got equity in
your house and like Rachel said you
could do a lateral move if you stay you
know you you have enough to be able to
pay for this Middle Ground period And I
think one thing that gives me Comfort is
that you're not super far from the
parents like it would be different if
we're talking about there in Texas and
you're in New Jersey but thankfully
they're 30 to 45 minutes and I know it'd
be great to be you know 20 minutes or
even five minutes away but you have a
lot working for you in this situation
yeah in the midst of some challenges
yeah so Jennifer I would get through the
surgery and all of that with your
husbands and then see what extra you
have and since it's just thirteen
thousand with your income you could just
knock that out and then look to move you
know in November I mean you could wait
another you know six eight months if you
wanted to uh considering how close you
are but I think moving I would do that
yeah in the next year if you guys can
because I know you want to be close to
your family so thank you so much for the
call this has been a great hour thank
you Christina for co-hosting and thank
you America for listening this is the
Ramsey Show
hey it's Christina Ellis if you like
what you heard in this episode and want
to know more about getting started on
the Ramsay baby steps go to
ramsesolutions.com and click on the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramseysolutions.com and click get
started
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
ERS of at Ramsey Solutions broadcasting
from the PODS moving and storage Studio
it's the Ramsey show where we help
people build wealth do work that they
love and create actual amazing
relationships I personality Rachel Cruz
hosting today with best-selling author
and Ramsey personality Christina Ellis
and we are taking your calls it's a free
call anywhere in the country at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
we'll talk about your life your money
your job your relationship anything and
everything Christina and I are here to
walk you through your situation so uh if
you guys have enjoyed this show and it's
something that you think gosh this has
helped me it has changed my life
we want you to share it that's one of
the best ways to continue to spread the
word is share it subscribe to the
channel leave a review and honestly just
tell your friends and family about it
you know we sit in these chairs every
day for three hours because we want to
help people become free from their money
and money is such a it's such a shameful
burdensome burden close yeah close topic
and creates a lot of stress a lot of
anxiety and to be free from that is
something we want we want you guys to
have healthy relationships with the
people in your life that you love we
want you to have a job and a career that
you're passionate about that you feel
like you're in the right seat so us help
us spreading hope is something that we
love and again giving you Direction and
hopefully some inspiration to be able to
do that so if that has been your
experience please share the show so
other people can get that as well and if
you are a new listener and you want to
dive deeper into the Ramsay baby steps
go to ramseysolutions.com and click the
get started button and we're going to
help you figure out the next best step
for your financial Journey based on
exactly where you are today so that's
ramseysolutions.com and click get
started and that's a that's a great
resource again you know we may be
throwing out words like baby steps
gazelle intensity all these things and
you're like oh my gosh I'm new to this
so being able to know exactly where you
are will tell you that next step that
you need to take in order to do the baby
steps and again become financially free
where your money doesn't control you
anymore that you really do control it
it's funny I sometimes forget all these
words that people don't know that aren't
you know listeners for several years and
we were hosting FPU at church last night
and I was checking people in and I was
like are you here for FPU and somebody
was like what is FPU I was like oh my
gosh I'm so sorry Financial Peace
University
[Laughter]
so you're confused with all the acronyms
you're in good company that's right
that's right so good all right well
we're gonna go to the phone so we have
rich in Ashburn Virginia up next hey
Rich welcome to the show
good afternoon thank you for taking my
call absolutely how can we help well so
I'm a uh recently retired uh 51 year old
um I've got
um we've I've been following Dave Ramsey
for a long time I was gifted a book by
my brother years ago and uh I I followed
it to the T and um my my problem now is
that I I can't pull the trigger to enjoy
life I retired early because I I want to
enjoy the fruits of my labor and all the
sacrificing that we've done uh up to
this point but I can't let go of of that
money and that that mindset and you said
you're 51 rich
I'm 51 my wife is also 51 and she's got
about another two months and she's going
to be retiring amazing what did you got
what do you guys do or what did you do
uh my wife worked uh worked for Edward
Jones investments uh she was basically
an office manager
um and I was an air trust controller
good for you oh that's a stressful job
so give us an example what's that
purchase that you've wanted to make
recently that you're like oh I just
can't do it
so I'm a car Enthusiast
um I've I've always loved Corvettes
um I went to a dealership about three
weeks ago my wife and I we we agreed
that this was a lifelong thing I've
always wanted I went in there we we made
the deal that that we wanted we were
happy with it
I left the dealership I told the guy I
said let me sleep on it the next day I
called back and I said I I I'm not
buying a car I just couldn't pull the
trigger I couldn't spend the money
to enjoy life to start enjoying and I'm
afraid that I'm not going to be able to
do that every time something comes up
whether it be a trip or you know how
much you guys average what what's when
your wife retires in two months how much
is in retirement for you guys
so we have a total of 1.7 uh in net net
worth we have um I I have a car payment
right now on a car that I don't like
and that's why I want to I want to get
something that I'm going to enjoy and I
want to pay it off and be done with it
um but but yes so so 1.7 is where we're
at that's with her 401 my 401 she's got
an IRA
um I have individual stocks well good
job on the net worth I'm curious why do
you have a car payment
uh so what happened was I I got rid of a
car that I had
um around uh 2020 when the the car
market went ballistic and uh I bought a
car that I thought I may like and I
ended up liking it not loving it
um I just don't want to get rid of it
because I don't want to lose my tail on
it but why didn't you pay cash for the
car versus financing it
um because it was a lot of money that
the vehicle that I that I uh bought was
a uh it was sixty three thousand dollars
um and I I got a little bit for the car
that I traded in so I said well let me
just if I like this car and if I do I'll
pay it off and that was the plan as soon
as I retired paid off but I just don't
know how much is yeah Rich how much do
you guys have
in liquidity like how much liquid cash
because some of the this retirement is
tied up in roths and
um IRAs and 401ks what do you have
that's that's a liquid that you can get
to
uh right now I can get to nine we have
nine right around 91 92 000 and on a
savings account
um but I'm special Provisions which
means that I can I can access my my 401
uh now without penalty yes not that I
plan on it I don't plan on touching it
yet I don't have anything I've except
for that car that I want
um but I'm you know I'm just trying to
stay away from it as much as I can let
it build a little bit more before before
we enjoy it we don't plan on leaving
that for the kids the kids are growing
out of the house to this school they're
gone
um and you know we just we just want to
start enjoying life but I just for sure
I have a problem with pulling that
trigger I'm just a little bit confused
um just want to make sure I understand
everything 63 000 for a car that was a
pretty expensive car
um for somebody it's pretty Frugal and
it was and so is it let me give you a
little bit of this so I'm just confused
yeah because because that was pulling a
trigger on a pretty big purchase so I'm
confused at like what was the trigger
pulled thin and I'm kind of wondering if
like the the icky feeling in your
stomach right now whenever you go to buy
the other cars just simply because you
still have debt on this other expensive
car right well so the plan was to trade
in that car and then purchase the the
the the the car of my dreams uh and pay
pay cash for so how much will you be out
of pocket if you went and bought the
Corvette that you want and tried the car
it was about 78 000 78 000. 78 okay yeah
so rich what I would do I mean bring
your net worth standpoint you can afford
the car you can afford the car but I
want to make sure that you are debt free
you guys have a good savings uh safety
net for your emergency fund but start
running numbers out for your retirement
sit down with an investment Pro Smart
investor Pro and really run these
numbers out to to know exactly where you
can give yourself permission to spend
because yeah you are 51 and you want to
make sure your Investments are growing
you can live off what you want to live
off of and have the ability to do that
and this is an incredible number so
you're you're probably going to be able
to and then that will give you
permission to enjoy life so thanks for
the call Rich this is the Ramsey Show
foreign
[Music]
look I love real estate and I want you
to have a house but I don't want a house
to have you
that's why you need to get in touch with
Churchill Mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for you that means
they check in every year with free
consultations to help you stay on the
right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice basically they care
that's why we call them Ramsay trusted
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and Churchill is here to help go to
their site churchillmortgage.com Ramsey
to start your approval or get more
information
foreign
[Music]
if you're looking to sell your home
right now it can be really intimidating
it can be a very intimidating process
and since the demand is still higher
than Supply home Rises are still rising
and buyers in this market are serious
about finding a deal and that means you
may have some tough decisions to make on
a tight timeline but look you don't have
to sell your home alone and you
shouldn't it's important work it's
important that you work with an expert
real estate agent who knows your local
housing market inside and out and who
will walk with you through the selling
process step by step having someone on
your side that knows what they're doing
you guys is so so key so you need a real
estate agent again that is trusted and
who's earned the right to be called
Ramsay trusted because you know us here
at Ramsey that we have a high standard
for people that we work with and so
these Pros have been highly vetted they
are top tier agents that again we trust
here at Ramsey Solutions and they have
what it takes to sell your home on your
terms for the best price
if you are ready to sell your home get a
Ramsay trusted Pro in your corner it's
free to connect today just go to
ramseysolutions.com agent to find one
near you again that's
ramseysolutions.com
agent up next we have Andrew and Fort
Collins Colorado hey Andrew welcome to
the show
hey thank you it's an honor to speak
with you today absolutely how can we
help
well uh I am currently trying to figure
out kind of what to do with my life and
career my next steps are
um then slowly working through Ken
Coleman's book processing other people
in their life and
um really like soaking that in and it
seems my next steps maybe like further
education or certifications
um
to
sort of fulfill the desire that God gave
me to replicate the censorship program
that I was left to be involved in and uh
transformed through but in the meantime
I've been working at a job which I don't
really see a future for myself in
um
just feeling kind of stuck in it a
little bit and you know it wouldn't get
any closer to my goals
and dreams
um what kind of job is it and
um it is doing sales uh kind of front
counter sales it's a good company a good
job for like people to work with
and then what is this
yeah what's the dream what's the
discipleship program
right it's
um a year-long program that I got to be
involved with in New York It's A
discipleship program largely focused on
like outdoor Ministry and
um
so do you want to work for this program
or you want to create a company that
does something like that what's your
vision with that
ideally like
would be to create a sort of a sister
program to that
um here in Colorado
um because it you know it's at the point
where it can be replicated
have you talked to the people who have
you talked to the people who lead this
program like what would it take for you
to be able to open a similar program and
work with them through that process
that's I am still trying to figure out
actually
um I have spoken with him a few years
back
um and I kind of put it on on hold for a
little while so what does you know sort
of at the point where I'm ready to like
start moving forward with something else
okay so what you said that you think the
next step is probably a certification
program or some form of Education how
does that play into getting you to the
discipleship program
okay
well when I talked to
um the program director a few years ago
he you know recommended taking getting a
few certifications and like more more in
terms of like outdoor meeting like
leading outdoor trips
um and
um along that route and
I guess I haven't really done that yet
um okay like I said I was kind of
putting that to the side so a little so
I know this is something that you've
obviously been really impacted by and
you love and you believe in
um do you do you see a really feasible
realistic route of yeah starting a
branch there in Fort Collins or
somewhere in the you know where you're
going to live and start that program and
you know like like is it is it more just
gosh this thing changed my life and I
want to do something like it eventually
um or is like no there's actually a
really clear path on how to do this and
the sister company or the you know the
the organization that put it on
originally is willing to do it with you
you know what I mean like where where
are you in that process
I'm kind of moving from like you know
wanting to do it eventually to
um actually doing it and it's a and it's
realistic to do it right like you've
talked to them and they said yes
absolutely we would love for you to do
that you just need to do X Y and Z and
it is possible like do you feel like
that they have a
um that there are certain certain that
you can
well no no I'm not quite to that point
though okay would you ever start your
own
disciples are not to like rip off their
idea because I know there's probably
like trademarking and all of that but
but um do you think that that it is
realistic to do maybe a branch where you
are or do you think you're going to
start something completely on your own
um you know I I do believe it'd be
realistic you know when I talk to them a
couple years ago
um it it went well you know what about
if you if you worked for this company
for a while like I don't know if you're
up for moving but potentially moving to
where they are and doing the day-to-day
work with them because it is different
going through the program it's amazing
that it was impactful to you but then
actually working and doing the work it's
going to be a different experience and
it would probably be nice to know do you
enjoy that experience with the
discipleship program versus being an
attendee
are you open to that oh right like kind
of getting more experience in the space
I would be
um I guess it'd be a little hard to pull
off you know logistically
being that I'm married my wife has a
good job here and
um yeah yeah what about even just like
trying Ministry like a the discipleship
program sounds amazing but is there some
other form of ministry that might be
interesting to you maybe you could work
for a church for a while and disciple
people within the church like kind of
just getting your feet wet in the space
and getting like used to what that kind
of work is like
there yeah there's definitely that
opportunity which I have been involved
with from like with young young life and
I can definitely do some more with my
church too yeah
um yeah I would say Andrew I love young
life by the way that's where Winston and
I met so I'm a big fan big fan of them
um yeah they're great so yeah I and
actually that's a great example young
life for on a personal note is something
that we love and we support financially
we're obviously not on Young Life staff
we're doing it so I was going to say too
sometimes when you go through something
that's really impactful and changes your
life you know that there's even with
another curriculum separate from Young
Life last year and gave to them
throughout the year because you're just
like oh wow I want to help in some way
and it may not be my full-time career uh
but I I love it so much and sometimes
sometimes that loving it and life change
can get mixed in with this is what I
want to do with my life vocationally
sometimes it is right it does change
your life you're like oh no I'm putting
my whole life into it and sometimes it's
like hey I can have a passion for this
thing that changed my life and help in
other ways but the things that draw me
to it maybe there's another to your
point Christina of like a another type
of ministry another route to take that
you still use those passions and those
gifts and maybe in the meantime Andrew
but it sounds like you haven't talked to
them in a few years it still sounds
really up in the air so if I were you I
would have a call with that company that
you love that was out I think of New
York you said
um and and I would say hey I would love
a serious call to say what are the steps
that I need to take specifically because
they said certifications and all of that
and get an actual list of what it would
take financially do you need donors do
you have to have you know an established
location for that like like get a lot of
the details Andrew and I think that's
going to help you weed out hey this is
something I could actually do here in
the next five years or man this may be a
15-year dream and between now and then I
need to kind of find something that is
more than just a sales job because I
want to go to a place that I love every
day and work and make money and do my
passion or anything you're reading about
Ken Coleman but I think for if I were
you I would get more hard facts from
them and I think that's going to help
you make the decisions and you and your
wife sit down and say okay is it worth
investing into this this licensing or
this training and know how much all
those are and if you guys have the money
for it I mean it's kind of that big
picture but getting more specific does
that make sense
it does yeah well I think part of it is
just going to be taking all together
taking steps like taking those action
steps I think you've had these dreams
for a while you've been feeling this for
a while but there's kind of fear around
actually getting a certification
reaching out calling the company getting
those detailed steps you need to take
next and I think that's when you're
really gonna feel more clarity yes yep
facts are going to help you in this
Andrew so thanks for calling this is the
Ramsey Show
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees ever
three things backed by their 100 percent
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free see whyblinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings visit blinds.com to
save up to 40 percent off everything
site-wide go to blinds.com for more
information
[Music]
foreign
if you're planning to move soon you know
it can be so expensive but I've got
great news our studio sponsor PODS
moving and storage wants to help one of
you move for free so just get a quote at
pods.com Ramsay between February 20th
and March 3rd and enter to win it's
really that simple and one listener will
get a free move valued up to five
thousand dollars and this is crazy ten
thousand dollars in cash so if you're
doing the math yep that's a total value
of fifteen thousand dollars so look pods
it just makes moving easier with the
flexibility you need the control you
want and the customer service you
deserve if you're looking for a company
that will help you move on your terms
pods is the only Ramsay trusted moving
provider out there so go to pods.com
Ramsay to enter today to win a free move
and again ten thousand dollars cash
today that's pods.com
AMC up next we have Dawn in Duluth
Minnesota hey Don welcome to the show
thank you hello Rachel and Christina
thank you for taking my call absolutely
how can we help
well I am debt free except for my house
yay and I have been congratulations
for about I don't know
and but I still have all these other
things like a roof I have to save up
money for lawyer fees because of stuff I
have to go through with my one of my
children and I just keep feeling
like I'm not
getting where I want to go because all
these other things keep coming up yeah
life keeps happening I
yes so I have a three-month emergency
fund right now because the other stuff
needs to be paid for because I
I have to do it via cash
that's right and I've been following you
guys a step for a long time and I just
keep feeling like I'm just not getting
anywhere and the motivation keeps going
down for sure so how much do you make a
year Don
um about 55 to 60. okay
and you said you are debt free with
everything but the house since about
nine months ago is that correct
yeah so yeah the main major part of it
so did you pay off a bunch of debt what
was the journey before that
um so I started kind of uh August of
um or no sorry August of 18. I really
started
um listening to you guys I heard about
you guys years ago at my church and I'm
like I'm gonna do that I'm gonna do that
and then it comes and goes
so August of 18 I decided you know what
a couple of that I work with
um did it and were I'm a nurse and so I
did have the opportunity to work more
and get paid more and as of February
22nd I was debt free with credit cards
um I bought a new newer vehicle to me
with cash
um paid off my student loans
um paid
about twenty thousand dollars in uh
lawyer fees
um since August of 20 or sorry August of
18.
and so it's it's been a journey yeah
you've been through a lot
yeah but I keep feeling like I should be
farther
I think that's this is such an
interesting question because I think
we've we've all felt that a bit at times
where it's like you you work through all
these steps you get your emergency fund
and then Murphy still hits there's still
roof repairs there's still things like
that and sometimes I just wish you could
just like pause everything else and it's
like okay life don't happen like cars
aren't allowed to go out now I finally
hit this spot like why can things still
go wrong like it's frustrating so Don uh
how much will the roof cost
I'm getting a for sure estimate
um in a week and a half
um but I am estimating probably seven to
ten seven to ten okay and the lawyer
fees what how much will those be
um well so I've paid off all of it I'm
supposed to go back to mediation I'm
hoping only two to three okay but that's
still like oh I could just go towards my
roof I know yeah I know I hear you I
hear you yeah yeah so I think in the
meantime I did put 4 000 into my vehicle
after I bought it oh good yeah that's
great that's great
yeah so I think one of the things Don is
after you paid off debt which is usually
like the exciting goal that a lot of
people have they work towards and so
much of their motivation and all that is
going goes towards that that you need
something else that you're looking ahead
that isn't just roof repairs and lawyer
fees but have something out there Don
that you're like oh okay in five years
this is a big goal I have and I don't
know if it's a great vacation you want
to take I don't know I don't know what
it would be whatever it has done for you
but have something in the next three to
five years that is out there that's fun
and enjoyable that you're looking
forward to because what you're listing
out it sucks right I mean like life
sucks what would suck more is if you had
car payments and student loan payments
and credit card bills every month on top
of this which you don't have which you
can celebrate that for sure
um and so that's that's the progress
that you've made by getting out of debt
having an emergency fund is that like
you actually have when your paycheck
hits you have the ability to use it for
these things versus again hundreds and
hundreds maybe even thousands of dollars
going back out and and debt payments so
that's a great thing but I just want I
want you to have something that is
exciting to you and can bring you Joy
that you work towards in the midst of
all this life right and again I know a
lot of your money will be going towards
the roof and the lawyer fee but again
have out there okay after these are are
done like this is what I'm shooting for
because when you have a goal I mean it's
it is motivating there's something about
that changes the way you look at your
budget it changes all of it and when
it's a goal that you want again and
everyone out there listening it could be
an emergency fund it could be a goal of
getting out of debt whatever that thing
is that you want it changes the way you
spend money changes the way you save
money but what you what you listed off
Don it's like adulting expenses that we
all have and they're pricey uh but it's
kind of one of those things that you're
like God you have to do it
um and it's not fun so I I get that I
hear you Don do you have any idea what
that exciting thing could be for you
I would like to say that it's something
like
a really enjoyable like a vacation but
my five-year one of my five-year goals
is to actually pay my house off which is
super exciting but it's not like
take a trip with the family kind of
thing yeah it's great and you know what
and we talk about stopping and smelling
the Roses yeah being intentional in the
season so honestly Don I mean again I
would encourage even if it's a weekend
trip like yes have something fun I mean
I know paying off the house is important
we're all about that but this is the
time just to be intentional and to enjoy
the fruits of your life you don't have
to be gazelle intense in this process of
where you're at so so maybe you still do
a vacation before you pay off the house
how do you feel about that problem
I think you should I think you should
don't stop well that's probably part of
it too is it's like you were in baby
step two and then you were saving your
emergency fund and you were gazelle
intense and it's like that that switch
hasn't flipped but at the same time
you're not feeling super motivated right
now because it's like wait you don't you
need to be motivated but it's a
different kind of motivation and I think
you're wanting to feel the motivation of
baby step two but you don't have to
quite be that intense like Rachel said
it's intentional and intentional can
include vacations
yeah and I'd really like to get up to a
six-month emergency fund
um but I stopped at three so that I
could start putting money away for
yeah and I think do both and stuff yes
for sure and I think that's wise I mean
your three month is there so I think
you're doing exactly what you need to do
Don we're just saying to get you through
it and to have a little bit more joy
enjoyment of this process is to have a
thing that you that Don just wants Don
just wants this out there and after the
roof is done and again the lawyer fees
and everything and if Don wants a
six-month emergency fund and that sounds
better than a vacation and make that
your next goal right like it doesn't
matter what it is but I just want you
to be working towards something that you
uh are excited about and and enjoy
because that's what money is right you
do all of this
so that you have freedom with your money
you do all of this to change your family
tree uh you do all of this so that money
doesn't control you it's a tool to
create a life that you love and we want
you to do that and you've done the hard
work done and I know you still have a
few maybe another year or two of that
hard work with all of this but we want
you to to enjoy and love your life too
yeah and you can get really tactical
with it like at you can say at the end
of paying off my roof at the end of
these lawyer fees and once I get three
more months of an emergency fund boom
we're going to Disney World that's right
yes yep have it out there have that that
fun goal out there that's important
thanks Don for the call this is the
Ramsey Show
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
the price hikes everything from food to
gas to just life it just feels like the
new Norm of what we pay is is crazy and
it's not just us feeling the pain yeah
Walmart is feeling the pain Walmart is
pushing back against major product
suppliers who are asking for higher
prices so this was an interesting
article that came out that said that
Walmart is warning major package good
makers that it can no longer stomach
their high prices and are going to pitch
their own private label products to
Shoppers that are less expensive it's a
less expensive alternative option to buy
their private label products versus the
the main labels you know the the labels
that you see that you're like oh yeah
the name brand stuff so yeah okay
they're really going to scrutinize any
price hikes by retailers because they're
saying that any of those especially I
think we're in this culture right now
with inflation where it kind of feels
like people are raising prices and it's
like people just keep buying no matter
what so Walmart's saying like this is
impacting our customers and we're
reaching that that Tipping Point where
it's like even just a few cents more
it's gonna hurt people so we've got to
push back because there's only so much
space people have in their budgets you
know before they start going we can't
afford this that's right absolutely so
um yeah I think that it's a I think it's
a good discussion in general that when
you shop there are options and there are
options on what you buy the type of
product you're buying whether it is
generic or name brand uh and all of it
and it and it matters right I'm like
when you do grocery runs or you're
buying you know whatever it is hygiene
products or whatever like you're having
to buy this stuff look at the prices
because it adds up it does and I think
it's important kind of to break the
stigma around like where you shop so I
know a lot of people now like don't go
to Walmart and I know that there's like
ethical reasons and all of that but but
some people just don't want to go
because they they say it's like the like
the cheaper Target or it's like just not
a school I think they feel uncomfortable
but I'm still pretty Shameless going to
Walmart like I love like a good deal and
I think it's still great so I think if
you're not going to some of the discount
stores just because you feel like you're
embarrassed to go in or you don't want
to be shopping there like I would get
rid of that shape yes and just do what
you've got to do for your family even
like dollar stores Dollar Tree yes like
they still have amazing deals we've been
going there for cards recently like
birthday cards I'm like why why is it
six dollars at other stores oh that's my
dollar 25 years all of my Christmas uh
wrapping and package stuff all comes
from the Dollar Tree that's like I don't
go I don't go anywhere else because I'm
like it is it's so cheap but that and
groceries even you guys where you shop
so like an Aldi I mean there's these
places that have great prices and
sometimes you pay for the store
experience uh not just the quality of
the food for their prices right like I
can think of some grocery stores and
it's like they're more expensive
and their aisles are wider it's more
aesthetically pleasing like you know
like there's parts of the experience
that I think then they jack up the
prices even for that so but I'd rather
like I'd rather go to a spa with the
hundred dollars I have left at the end
of the month because I shopped at Aldi
versus going through a more
aesthetically leaving grocery store
that's right that's right I know so you
guys again look at what you're buying
and where you can save money because I
know for so many people the the margin
on the budget has has shrunk and you're
feeling in the pinch well I am Rachel
Cruz Ramsay personality hosting with
Christina Ellis and we are taking your
calls America at triple eight eight two
five five two two five and up next we
have summer in Orlando Florida Hey
Summer welcome to the show
Hi how are you thanks for having me
absolutely how can we help
so I was calling because
um I have saved up a good amount of
money in my savings account and I just
not quite sure what to do with it at
this point
um because I want to make the most of my
money yeah that's a great question okay
so how much do you have saved in the
bank
about 130 000. great job and is that
just in a checking account a traditional
savings a high yield traditional
traditional savings traditional savings
okay
um do you have any debt right now
no no dad and how did you save up that
130 was it just gradual or did you get a
big payout of something
No I um I've been working at the same
companies since I was 15 I've been here
26 years wow
um I just over time
um
I got divorced about 10 years ago and
just be myself raising my two daughters
and
several years ago I moved in with my
sister after sold the house and stuff
and kind of saved up a lot of during my
money then
um so for the past few years I've been
renting
and I'm I want to buy a home so I've
been kind of saving up for that I just
the market right now is is really high
and so I'm
I'm not ready to buy
um
so yeah my money is just kind of sitting
in the bank do you have any Investments
do you have any Investments right now
I have about
uh 40 some thousand in a Edward Jones
account that I have that's invested into
different stocks and stuff
um that's separate and then I also
through my employer I have
um a significant amount for my
retirement well I wouldn't say something
how much is that how much
about four hundred thousand okay okay so
you've been setting this money aside
intentionally for a house is that
correct
the money in the bank yes yeah the 130
like my retirement is just that's for
later you know that's my what my
employer has you know the stocks and
stuff in the company and then I have my
401k
um all that separate but just my savings
is kind of just sitting there and it's
not growing and it's not yeah and I was
kind of scared to invest it because I do
want to buy a house and I wanted to have
a good
down payment
um but it's just it's not moving yeah so
what I would do summer is I know you you
probably will purchase something I'm
assuming in the next year or two so I
would move it to a high yield savings
account or a money market account we
were just talking to our investment uh
Pro yesterday my husband and I and we're
we have Ally Bank and we just have a
high yield with them and it's 3.3
percent which is pretty great for just
sitting there you know and so yeah you
can make a whole lot more than a
traditional savings so I would
definitely take that 130 move it to a
high yield savings account again you can
do this on an online bank some brick and
mortar Banks but I would make sure to
check the rates uh and make sure you
compare it and do usually online I I
like online banks usually for this stuff
I don't know it just kind of makes it
easy and I don't know well that's part
of why they can give such great interest
rates brick and mortar that's right so
uh I would I would move that money there
summer and then I would contact a Ramsay
trusted real estate agent and just talk
to someone and say hey I'm really
thinking about buying I'm nervous
because the market fills up here's my
cash position and they're at least going
to be able to help you and understand
okay what's going on in the markets and
look at options because are your your
kids are grown is that right you said
you had two daughters are they grown and
out of the house
well one of my daughters
um is she's grown she's 24 she's
expecting to have oh we have my first
grandchild oh congratulations 15 months
and my youngest she's um 16 she's still
I'm with me so okay that's great yeah
yeah so I think the next move would be
uh to purchase purchase a home and you
know and since it's you guys you know
maybe some are even like a town home or
something you know it doesn't have to
condo yeah I mean you could look at well
I was kind of holding off because my um
I have a big family and my sisters they
all own their homes and we were talking
about purchasing land and getting houses
built like next to each other on the
land okay but I'm kind of waiting on
them and it's like I don't know when
that's gonna happen and so it's like do
I buy something now and then have to
sell it in a couple years or you know
like I I've that's something I have to
decide with them but yeah for sure I
would kind of get a poll or something
and make sure that that if you do choose
to go an option with them that sounds
awesome and amazing but also make sure
it works with you with you financially
and how land deals work and all of that
that kind of ends up being a little bit
convoluted but it's possible but just
make sure again that you don't get roped
into something that puts you back
financially number one and if it feels
like yeah it's kind of something we want
to do eventually but there's if there's
no prospects on land if there's nothing
tactical happening if I were you summer
I would I would you have the money so
I'm like I would go ahead and purchase
something this is what that money's
earmarked for there's no reason that
that you don't have to you can wait for
the market but again I would I would
contact the Ramsay trusted real estate
agent because they'll be able to walk
you through the real estate side of it
but but today with that 130 I would
definitely since you're debt free all
that I would put in a high yield savings
and then I would look at the real estate
market and I think that's a next great
move and then continue to invest in your
retirement and keep going but you're
doing a great job summer I know as a
single mom there is a lot on your plate
and you're doing a real really fantastic
job so I'm glad I'm glad you called in
well thank you Christina for hosting
today with me and thank you America for
listening this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
hey it's Rachel Cruz if you love this
show and want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we have a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you trending and
helpful articles and tips on following
the Ramsay way just go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramseysolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
foreign
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS of
moving and storage studio in the Ramsay
show where we help people build wealth
do work that they love and create actual
amazing relationships it is a free call
anywhere in the country at AAA
825-5225 and I'm Ramsey personality
Rachel Cruz hosting today with Ramsey
personality and the best-selling author
Christina Ellis so go right to the
phones this hour with Joel and
Charlotte's hey Joel welcome to the show
hi thank you guys for having me on
absolutely how can we help
um I am currently a community college
student here in the Charlotte area and I
did dual enrollment during High School
which obviously saved a lot of money
it's absolutely amazing uh and currently
have 60 credits college credit
um and I'm looking to transfer to a
four-year University and looking for
some help on scholarships and whatnot my
parents have some funds that are saved
up for me uh for college but they stated
that if I don't use all those funds that
I will get them after I complete college
so I want to try to use as little as
possible when it comes to that
um so I'm just wondering what
suggestions you have for finding
scholarships and whatnot I love this
question
Christina is here for you Joel I am here
for this awesome and I just love that
you're also selling the idea of doing
dual enrollment which gets a lot of the
credits out of the way early on that
you're going to Community College like
you are modeling
such a great path
the fact that you're already right here
like just hand clap to you because that
is that is outstanding
um so where are you thinking about going
for the next two years or however long
you've left um
so I'm looking either online or in
person I'm looking at Regent University
which is a Christian University and
Virginia Beach area
um their online program is approximately
thirteen thousand dollars a year uh and
then their in-person program which
includes room and board is twenty eight
thousand dollars a year so obviously
there's about a fifteen thousand dollars
difference there okay and are you still
pretty open to where you go like that's
somewhere that you're considering but
you're open to other options is that
correct I'm open to other options
um I would prefer to go to this school
but obviously I am open to other options
okay well I like to typically start the
search pretty broad like one of the
easiest and best ways to get
scholarships is through the school so if
you pick the right school that has a lot
of merit-based scholarships or
need-based Aid if you're qualified for
that like that's going to be the easiest
way because a lot of these scholarships
they're just part of the application so
if you go to the financial aid website a
lot of times you can see most schools
have listed like basically if you have
this GPA and these test scores then this
is the automatic scholarships you get at
this school so that's helpful a lot of
schools too have no price calculators on
their website so you can type in your
financial information and see basically
what you'll be expected to pay at that
school because a lot of schools the
sticker price when you go to their
website it's like oh my gosh that's so
expensive but that's not typically what
you actually pay so
um yeah kind of first seeing if you can
get a lot of scholarships for a school
through school is a great way and then
also checking with your state so states
have a lot of great a lot of states have
great scholarships so seeing you know
what you're eligible for through that so
again starting Broad and then start
narrowing down so
um I know this sounds so basic and
sometimes people are like oh I can't
believe she's recommending this but
Google searches are still excellent ways
to find scholarships so there's the
great thing about scholarships there's
so many different scholarships available
for so many different interests so I
always encourage people to write out
their Niche scholarship qualities so
things that could potentially qualify
them for a scholarship so if you're in
4-H if you run cross-country if you're
in the business Club if you want to be
in stem write all that stuff down and
then search for scholarships that
specifically
Target those students so you know just
get in Google and type in scholarships
for students in stems scholarships for
people in Business scholarships for
students who like horses it's like
literally almost anything you can think
of there's a scholarship for at this
point so like getting in there and as
you look at the Google search results a
lot of times you'll see either like a
compilation of scholarships which those
can be great but what's really good is
if you can find like the site that's
directly giving away the scholarships so
if you can find there's a scholarship by
the National Horse Club if you if you
can click directly on their website
that's going to take you directly to the
information you need and help you get
started with the process and then
there's scholarship databases which are
also great so they're basically you know
these search engines that take those
unique qualities and they filter through
the millions of scholarships that are
given away every year and they basically
come up with a list of scholarships that
fit you so I typically recommend
students use use a few scholarship
search engines usually three because
each engine typically matches you with
different scholarships so you want to
get as many results as possible that are
targeted to you so use a few different
search engines and then make your list
because a big part of the scholarship
process is there are so many
scholarships out there and it can feel
kind of overwhelming but taking the time
on the front end to create a really good
list for you is going to save you so
much time in the long run because as you
know I can already tell on your voice
you're like yeah that's it's a lot
that's like one of the harder parts of
the process is actually the search
process because it's like I think that's
when a lot of people quit because they
just feel overwhelmed or they try one
search engine and they get matched with
scholarships that don't quite feel right
but if you're willing to take the time
on that front end even if it takes you
know five or six hours to come up with a
good list we're talking like thousands
of dollars in the long run so
um be willing to trudge through that
part
what's your thoughts on uh things like
scholarship owl where you like pay a
subscription and automatically uh
applies you for different scholarships
yeah so we've actually worked with
scholarship Al here at Ramsey and
they've they're friends of Ramsey
they're really passionate about matching
students with scholarships that really
fit them and kind of weeding out the bad
ones so one of the hard things about
scholarship databases right now is a lot
of these databases are just taking these
lists of scholarships and they're not
really updating them some of them are
scam scholarships some of them haven't
been updated in six years and they no
longer exist and so it's hard for
students because they get in there and
then they're like oh deadlink oh
deadlink so scholarship I was really
trying to yeah basically it's a great
it's a great member it's a great
subscription to do it they have a free
version and then they do have a paid
version and I we have found we've heard
a lot of people saying it's worth it
it's worth it because it saved that time
that time where you know if you're just
doing it can take five or six hours they
can kind of cut it down yeah absolutely
and school choice is always huge so if
you're not set on I know you kind of
said you were Joel but if you can
broaden your Horizon and say hey
wherever I can get money
to get as much money possible towards a
school I'm going to run after that yeah
and let that be it so that's so great
and I have an article on how to apply
for scholarships that we'll Link in the
show notes if you all want some more
information so good well Christina
scholarship time and it's tax time and a
lot of people have questions about taxes
and we get it taxes are so confusing so
to help you get a better handle on them
let's unpack a question from one of our
listeners they asked is it better to
file together or file separate when
married so the IRS actually won't force
you to do one or the other and there may
be some specific very specific scenarios
where it's a good idea to file
separately but for most couples it makes
more sense to file jointly and merge all
of your finances together for that
matter so filing jointly gives you a
higher standard deduction and makes you
eligible for more tax credits plus you
save time by only filing one return
versus two so it's a little less
confusing so for more tax tips and
software that can help you file with
confidence head to ramseysolutions.com
Smart Tech tax
ramseysolutions.com smart tax now
through the end of February you can file
your tax return at just 19.95 no hidden
fees no hidden hidden agenda
it's just that so go to
ramseysolutions.com
smart techs
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
our question of the day comes from
Michelle from Rhode Island we have a
one-year-old and have started receiving
monetary gifts for her we are not ready
for baby step five so what do we do with
it in the meantime a savings account
ideally we would like to put it
somewhere so it can accrue interest I
mean we've talked about high yield
savings accounts already on the show and
we're big fans right now especially with
interest rates being pretty high while
it isn't Fun for interest rates to be
high if you have debt if you're saving
right now it's pretty great I think ours
is at 3.75 and so uh about a year ago a
year and a half ago they were like one
percent so it wasn't necessarily very
attractive but right now they're doing
really great so if I was in your shoes
I'd probably park it there yeah for
right now for sure and then you can look
into if you want to a mutual fund or
something like that and you can put in
their name and yours is kind of over the
top and the university you Universal
transfer miners act upmods can allow you
to do that so you can sit down with the
smart investor Pro if you want to look
into that option but right now since
yeah they're one and you guys aren't
quite on baby step five as a family
um
yeah or I guess I guess kids college she
said not babysit five so I guess they're
thinking I could put this in a college
fund so if you did that opening up a 529
but I would imagine Michelle if it's not
I mean if you have like your great Uncle
Joe dies and leaves your one-year-old
like fifty thousand dollars and yeah
let's talk about putting that away like
in a bike ride but if it's like fifty
dollars from Grandma you know what I
mean like if it's if it's not a
significant amount I wouldn't worry
about it right now
um until you guys get to baby step five
then you can move some of that money to
a college savings account if that's what
you want to do but if it's a if it is a
legitimate pile of money then you may
want to be smarter about it or in a
sense of just saying like sit down and
look to see okay where can we invest
this
um now but if it's just a few hundred
bucks here or there then I think you're
fine and just a high yield savings for
now until you guys get to baby step five
then you can put some of that money yeah
I still have so many questions because
yeah it does matter how much it is yeah
because if it's just a small amount like
we still do the little piggy bank yeah
that's right that's right that's right
totally totally yeah but great question
all right it is a free call anywhere in
the country at triple eight eight two
five five two two five and up next we
have Sarah in Minneapolis hey Sarah
welcome to the show
hi Rachel hi Christina
hello hello how can we help yes I'm in
baby steps four five and six but I'm
just really struggling with the pull of
just doing it all at once I mean I want
my money to go so far and there's also
the
the Dark Cloud of my husband's car might
need a replacement in the next year so
deciding when to save for that
and then I saw your video yesterday on
lifestyle creep and so I've been a
stay-at-home mom the last five years and
the last couple of months since I've
been back to work I'm like oh no is that
me because we're not really making
progress on like these goals I feel like
and say I'm like oh we can have a
vacation now or I can say yes to some of
the things I've been saying no to for so
long yeah okay so what where should I
put my money yeah no it's a great
question so what caused you to go back
to work Sarah was it that you guys
needed the extra income or was it that
you were wanting to go back to work what
was what was your motivation for that
um no it was time like we were doing
just fine on my husband's income we were
still making like little progress in all
these areas not anything extreme because
we had to say no to a lot of things but
even last year I was still able to get a
newer van for me and we paid cash
fifteen thousand dollars like we still
had some yeah a little cushion in the
budget but now it's like
I have my whole income that we didn't
need so how much is your husband how
much does your husband make
um well all together our monthly income
like after taxes and everything we see
it take home about 10 grand a month and
we've never seen that amount before what
was it before you went back to work
um
before so he even got a raise after I
got back to work so we were really
playing with around five thousand
dollars a month maybe five yeah so you
all doubled your income
yes um which is so great so exciting so
even with that Sarah you you guys should
be able to fund 15 of your income into
retirement are you guys have y'all done
kids college at all have you started any
of that
yeah we started it but when I was
staying home we really pulled back a lot
so we're only doing like 200 a month we
have like twenty thousand dollars in so
far from the three kids and they don't
need college for another decade sure
sure I don't know how much to put there
yeah so what do you feel like has
changed in the lifestyle because you
said you know is it me like what where's
this money going like what what has
changed
yeah I guess I assumed when I went back
to work I just have all this extra money
in the budget well you doubled it and
yeah we doubled it but it's still it's
like you know the kids activities are
adding up
oh my God like two vacations booked this
summer and they're not like extravagant
but we're saying yes like to the grocery
store more like I'm not so worried about
the little nitty-gritty and now I'm
starting to realize maybe I need to go
back to just being very very frugal and
pretend we don't even have no yeah no I
mean no what I would say Sarah is I want
you guys to look at your what your
budget was when it was just his income
because you guys were doing it you were
you were living off of it and I'm sure
it was you know it was tight but you
were doing it so go back to there and
then I would up your lifestyle some
percentage points so maybe it's
six percent ten percent you know
whatever it is up it a few percentage
points and then say okay here's the
extra money a month now that we're gonna
put strictly to Lifestyle but we're
gonna limit it to That We're Not Gonna
spend like like nothing is happening and
we have like this Limitless amount of
money uh we're still going to be
intentional and then from there that's
where you can kind of work through and
say okay ten percent more is going you
know 10 is going to giving 10 more to
Lifestyle 15 to retirement you know you
can start kind of uh backing your way
out of those percentages into your
budget and then that will give you some
relief Sarah because I think sometimes
it can feel like especially since you
guys doubled it it can feel like oh gosh
okay so what do we what do we do now I
think yeah we can do that I think that's
fine and this you know it's almost like
you're kind of just being reactive to
some of this stuff and so the more
proactive you guys can be is is so key
do you guys have every dollar or
budgeting app
yes I've been using it for like the last
three years oh awesome everything so I
can go back even see yeah yeah I would
do that but I think that's a yeah I
think that's a great plan and just to
give yourself a little bit more of that
permission of like okay
we have this percentage that we're gonna
spend and enjoy because we're on baby
steps four through six and this is what
we can do and then above that we're
still gonna have to say no because
regardless of what you make everyone has
to say no at some point right like we're
not in Congress we're not just spending
money like like we have everything in
the world and so there is that level of
saying yeah I still have to be
disciplined regardless of what I make
but you should feel a level of Freedom
that you didn't feel before your income
was doubled so as as you've made more
money like what has that budgeting
process looked like have you
intentionally like Rachel said kind of
moved things up or has it been more like
reactive where you're like oh shoot like
we spent more here so let's just move
things around like what's your process
look like well I think I knew that I
could you know give a little more to my
grocery budget or say yes to that family
vacation this summer whereas before it
was just
camping in an old tent where now we can
maybe get like a little rental cabin
instead yeah it's not anything too crazy
it's just I still have like my husband's
car
it could die a year from now and even
living comfortably not too frugally I
could probably put away at least three
grand a month for that car should I
really focus on just
getting all that lump sum for 20 to 30
000 for a year from now and then go back
and revisit all of the
father baby steps the college fund but
paying extra for the mortgage and yeah I
mean what makes you think it's going to
die in a year
um it's got 250 000 miles on it okay so
you know you'll review yeah so I think
that's a realistic thing to say hey
we're going to replace this car
um and yeah and that's the sinking fund
and to say okay how much money do we
want to spend on a car and you guys
decide on an amount and then from there
yeah you you back it out so if it's 21
000 you can save three grand a month
towards a car and you got seven months
to save and put that aside in the car
fund and then when the car you know when
you it may even go 350 miles who knows
but but yeah but when it's time yeah
that you have the chunk there so yeah
it's just kind of working this but like
you said it's not Limitless yeah so you
do have to to plan once there maybe
maybe try a no spend month I know we
were kind of feeling that a bit last
year where it's like oh lifestyle creep
and your income changes and you're like
we'll just you just it's just easy for
you to lose some of that discipline with
your money and having that month where
you go all the way down to like a very
strict budget and it's not so that you
like live the rest of your life like
that but you're just kind of going okay
let's challenge ourselves and then see
what we really want so good so good
thanks for calling Sarah this is the
Ramsey Show
[Music]
foreign
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I am
Rachel Cruz hosting this hour with
Christina Ellis and we are hitting the
phones and up next we have Raya in
Charlotte North Carolina hey Raya
welcome to the show
bye ladies thanks for taking my goal
absolutely how can we help
well I am looking for a bit of
relationship advice disguised as
Financial advice ah yes yes
give it to us we can't wait
yeah I'm a 26 year old uh in step four
with no debt and I'm really proud of
that
um I make a good living and it's it's
wonderful and comfortable
um and my boyfriend of almost one year
is
probably in baby stuff one maybe even
zero I don't even know if he has an
emergency fund
and
um as we get more serious you know
beginning to talk about money just a
little not too specific
but I'm starting to get worried that
he's not as money Savvy as me and
I just want to know what things are
important to discuss and agree about
before getting serious in a relationship
yeah that's a great question so good I I
like love I love the description of this
and the kind of tiptoeing into it so
you've had these little conversations
how have these gone so far
yeah it's like vague and non-specific
but um you know references to student
debt card debt
um
things like wanting to buy a house even
though there's still so much debt so
that doesn't make sense to me but
um yeah okay
um Have you shared with him uh your
journey of becoming debt free and like
Have you shared any part of what you
love to do and that's or like what you
have done and what you have loved the
progress and all that how has he
responded to that
well okay okay disclaimer I got such a
huge Head Start in life so I never did
take on debt in the first place that's
okay yeah yeah so I had no student loans
I was um provided by my parents all of
that so I've discussed my financial
values a little bit but I know that
we're coming from such different places
in life that sure um it feels a little
bit almost irrelevant to share
um
yeah I I hear you because these are
things that I've never gone through so
absolutely well and let me say this it
doesn't invalidate
where you've been because there's one
line of thinking for sure that yes he
may not have had the doors open that you
had of going debt free he may not have
had the the parents maybe to walk
through and teach him about money maybe
like you had right so you could make all
these assumptions but also
um he is still making decisions as an
adult though
um and my curiosity is is it more
because it's ignorant and he doesn't
know there's another way or is it
because he doesn't care and he is
totally fine with debt regardless of
where he came from or not right because
we meet people on the show all the time
that that have paid off massive amounts
of student debt they were taught that
debt is awesome right they've been
taught this like world view of money and
they've decided as an adult to change
that world view and change their line of
thinking and make progress and get out
of debt and build an emergency fund and
do the things that you're doing so even
though he came from I totally hear that
maybe not where you started in a on a
different starting point but he still is
making decisions day to day as an adult
so are those decisions he's making
talking
because he doesn't know there's a
different way or is it because he's
totally just fine with what he's doing
uh yeah that's what I want to find out
oh
I we we talk about it a little I'm I
know he wants to get out of debt
I just feel that there's not an urgency
that I would feel if I was in that
situation and that kind of scares me
okay yeah you know if we got married one
day I mean I guess I'm being selfish but
or you know I don't want to be shallow
but I I want to be protective of my
financial future so I
yes that is not shallow at all no that
is wise that is that is wise that is
using wisdom because what happens right
in a marriage one of the leading causes
of divorce is money fights so many
problems because you get into a marriage
and stress the stress of money weighs on
a marriage so so much and ahead of time
if you guys can have the same values and
same perspective it helps you it doesn't
mean you have a perfect marriage and
that you're never gonna have a money
fight or any of that but it does give
you uh it puts you on the same playing
field of like Hey we're playing the same
game we're on the same team playing the
same game and so yeah I would sit down
and honestly Raya I'm like if it's been
a year
and you're in your mid-20s which granted
I'm like so Southern we got married
young and all that but like I would
think if I was in your shoes and I've
been dating this guy a year
I'm thinking obviously about marriage I
mean you are too of like okay am I gonna
spend the rest of my life with him and
if it's and if you love him and it's and
it's leading that way I would I would
sit down like hey
I kind of I just want to have this
conversation with you because I this
topic keeps coming up and I want to just
say it out loud and I have I have some
fear around this whole money discussion
and I don't know if it's me I don't know
if it's you I don't know I'm like and
don't accuse don't point fingers and say
you know all this but really leave it
open-ended but be honest about the
situation and what you're feeling and
then hear his feedback because he could
tell you either yeah screw that I don't
care I'm gonna just continue to live my
life the way I want and all that and if
that's his attitude with money it's
probably gonna be his attitude in other
areas of your marriage too right so like
that's a red flag but if he says yeah
I've thought about it so much and I've
actually written some goals down and I
haven't started because I'm scared right
like kind of get his part engaged where
he is before before you kind of slap you
know what you assume about it because
assumptions
aren't always key yeah and I got an idea
so we're gonna gift you FPU and I think
you have that initial conversation that
Rachel said you know kind of feel his
temperature and then in that say I'd
really like to take Financial Peace
University with you and go through it
together so that you know it eliminates
any type of excuse of he doesn't know
about money he didn't have parents who
taught him about money like he will know
what to do with money and then from
there you can see does he actually do it
is he going to take this wisdom and this
knowledge and move forward with it and
by the end if he doesn't if he's been
given all the tools and he decides he
just doesn't care that's going to show a
lot and on the flip side potentially he
could go yes and like completely go wild
with it and then you know in a year or
two you've got to completely debt-free
boyfriend that potentially is ready to
be a husband
yeah and I would say too Raya to
to give the whole situation like a a
little bit of Grace because you are so
um you are so motivated you are so on
track you know what you want you're
thinking about that like you're very
focused and so in our world we talk
about the nerd and the free spirit and
you know and you I'm just assuming it's
probably yeah you're the nerd okay so I
I can I talk to you as a free spirit my
husband is the nerd in our relationship
and I'm the free spirit and if he
expected me to love Excel sheets the way
he does looking at our five-year goal
and if I didn't love it and get excited
about it and he's like I'm not gonna
marry you because no matter something
crazy I think I'd be like oh my gosh do
I have to turn into a nerd to be your
wife you know what I mean like so so
don't force him to be someone who's not
so it's not changing who he is or his
personality but it is saying hey from a
values perspective do we agree of like
hey here are some big things with money
that that I want I want to be able to
put money away for retirement I am great
with delaying some gratification to save
for the future I don't have to spend
everything I make right now because I'm
pretty secure with who I am and I don't
need this stuff to fulfill me like you
know what I mean it's more of the value
the value conversations I want you to
have with them but don't expect him to
turn into a nerd Raya and like love this
and Christina was like don't watch
Netflix watch Financial Peace University
which I think is a great idea so stay on
the line you can do both and Santa's
gonna pick up and you're gonna have a
really exciting date night
with your boyfriend Raya watching
Financial Peace University he's gonna
love it no but just yeah I think it's
opening the door conversation because
again I mean if you want to get serious
and and again move to
marriage these are conversations and
Ryan you want to have conversations
around kids and around in-laws and
around spirituality like this is the
whole picture of marriage money is a
piece and an important piece yes
um but there's other there's other
pieces too so you guys need to be having
so be talking right I've been dating a
year you didn't get in those
conversations it is not selfish or extra
to want to know those things that's
right it's building a strong Foundation
that is smart you got it girl we're
cheering you on Raya we hope you guys
come and do your debt-free scream as
newlyweds maybe I'll get married and pay
off the debt together and be so exciting
okay thanks for calling this is the
Ramsey Show
foreign
[Music]
our scripture of the day comes from
Romans 12 at 10. love each other with
genuine affection and take Delight in
honoring each other
Aretha Franklin said we all require and
want respect man or woman black or white
it's our basic human right
Aretha Franklin Respect so good
r-e-s-p-e-ct I love that phone so so
great all right for the last segment
Angela is up next in Dayton Ohio hey
Angela welcome to the show
hey how are you doing we are doing well
how can we help
um first I want to say uh do you guys
remember the icky list that you guys had
done about um people consolidating the
deodorant stubbed into one yeah that was
us yesterday
yeah
that's that's totally me I I listen to
you guys
at work I don't know what you were
talking about you don't put the hair in
the pillow though right like cute oh God
no no we were talking about weird Google
hacks too me and George oh my gosh so
how long did it take you how long did it
take you to melt down all your deodorant
butts into one stick it only it really
only takes like two minutes
it's like 15 seconds in the microwave
and you just pour them into an empty
tube and it's so easy does it work just
I don't know which art this is it is for
me because I have been so ghetto poor
for the last three years that um four or
six dollars on a new tube of deodorant
it is gas money for Monday to work and
that is true that's a high value for me
okay you know what good for you and if
it only takes two minutes like why not
that's awesome I imagined it would take
longer kind of like digging digging out
all the deodorant like if you've ever
microwaved um icing in a microwave it it
takes just that long like 15 seconds it
even has that same consistency to it
okay it's a good April Fool's joke right
there
special
thank you Angela thank you Angela so
what's going on in your life how can we
help
um
okay so what I've got going on is um
like a family struggle when it comes to
money so
um I've taken like a like a 15 years the
battlefield away from my family because
they have a tendency to borrow money and
not pay it back and
um my brother on the other hand he's
he's doing really good in life like he's
worth over to two million dollars
and so when my parents need something
um he will call me and say you need to
pay half of those and I I just simply
don't have the funds I'm melting
deodorant to get by and
um so for me to come up with like 500 to
help fix something like a Plumbing or a
septic system I just don't have that and
um there's like quite a bit of bullying
tactics that are used on me when I tell
them I'll do what I can because I used
to just help and suffer the consequence
to my financial budget and
um I've been making such big surprise
I burn out and I'm just a hurt by their
inconsiderateness between me yeah yeah
you said I don't know if I heard this
correctly but did you say you took a
15-year sabbatical from the family
I did so there's there's some there's
some stuff there right right
um yeah I I definitely grew up um with a
good bit of them further reviews and
physical abuse and
um my brother was
um the favorite Child and he definitely
was not treated the same
and um I was born with
um
and then
masculine or atrophy
yeah and then I was always kind of seen
them as the um the burden
um
yeah so you you took this 15 years and
then you all came back together and and
your parents your brother's expecting
you to pay for your parents needs is
that correct like on their house right
do your parents right do they not have
money do they not have income
and they
um they didn't
manage their money properly
um and so I want to just release you
that they were working okay this is not
your responsibility
we can honor our parents but this is not
your responsibility and the fact that
your brother
is using bullying tactics against you
and then all the things that you were
just listing out of your childhood
growing up and then taking and then
having some boundaries around them in
the recent years I think there needs to
be another really hard conversation but
you need to protect yourself I mean
there's a level here that is not not
only that it's not fair for you it's
just wrong it's wrong the way that
they're treating you and again even if
you had the money
right even if you had it it's still your
money that you get to decide and if you
felt like yeah this is something I want
to be generous with with mom and dad
like I then I get to decide that as
Angela I'm not going to be forced into a
situation of what I don't need to do so
I don't know if it's a conversation that
you need to have with your brother and
draw a really hard boundary and just say
I'm not giving any more money
whether I have it or not I'm deciding
right now that I I don't like the way
this has been going down and so I'm
sorry but I I'm drawing that and he may
get all
angry and pissed and and I don't and who
knows what he'll say right I'm like I I
don't I don't know the situation
um but I think John deloney Dr John
deloney would say there that that you
need to protect yourself in a boundary
allows you to do that and yeah there's a
space between the 15-year Gap where it's
like you don't talk at all it's cold
turkey and the bullying and bad feelings
that you felt growing up and you know
they don't get to drag you into that as
an adult you're an adult now and I know
it's hard when you have childhood trauma
to put out boundaries like that's hard
because you're triggered whenever you
know they say those things it's like
you're all of a sudden you're 12 years
old again and you're feeling those
emotions but like Rachel said right yeah
you are released from that and and even
though it may feel mean even though when
you put the boundary up they are
probably not gonna like it they may even
say some mean things but that's okay and
that's why you put up the boundaries
yeah yeah they are they want to have
every conversation via text because
they're the kind of people that
screenshot things and post them on
Facebook and crop it to suit their
liking oh yeah no that's toxic yeah no
light as they can yeah I'm out it's it's
there's even a chance that this boundary
needs to be again where there's not a
lot of contact very often like that is
okay that's that's toxic and I'm sorry
you're going through that
um we're gonna gift you a copy of own
your past change your future by Dr John
deloney because I think there's going to
be a lot of healing for you in this
um in this next few years I think it's
going to take some time for you to
process a lot of that trauma and to kind
of work through it because man family
stuff can be so hard and especially when
they're still behaving that way it'd be
different if they had gone through their
own healing journey and weren't
counseling and we're trying to work and
repair things but it does not sound like
they are willing to change want to
change and if anything they're trying to
drag you right back in yes so I hope
Angela that you hear us just say you are
released from responsibility I think
financially and even relationally to a
point
um that there needs to be relational
boundaries and financial boundaries
really strong ones drawn so again um
yeah Jenna's gonna pick up and and read
Dr John Delaney's book because it is
really helpful to acknowledge what has
happened I mean it's it is all about
owning your past and we all have stories
of this right some the level of trauma
the stories look different
um but man there there's a lot there to
unpack for you Angela and so even get
with a good therapist and counselor if
you haven't yet because we everyone I
would recommend that to everybody
sitting down and unpacking your story
because it is so helpful to engage who
you are today and then help give you the
confidence to make decisions for what's
best for you Angela in your life and in
your money so I hope I hope you do that
so again General pick up and and you can
get a copy of that but well that's a
huge part of changing your future too is
it's like it's not like the past just
stays in a perfect box like you're still
dealing with these people in real time
so it's not like you can just you know
cut it off and that's it like it's like
you have to figure out new systems new
boundaries new ways to move forward
that's going to protect you and help you
have a full life because it's like when
you're constantly feeling that
negativity when those people are
constantly trying to drag you back into
your past it's like that can really hurt
you moving forward so you know feel the
freedom to set those boundaries and own
your future that's right absolutely
thanks Angela for the call well thank
you America that puts this show in the
books Christina Ellis it's always fun
hosting with you so much fun thanks so
so much and yeah thank you America for
listening this this is the Ramsey Show
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
hey it's Christina Ellis if you love the
show and want to dive deeper on your
money Journey we have a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you trending and
helpful articles and tips on following
the Ramsay way just go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramseysolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]